hi i'm joe manganiello and i'm here with
buzzfeed
to read your thirst tweets
i really find joe manganiello hot but i
refrain from saying that out loud in
public simply because i can't pronounce
his last name
that's a pretty common issue it's
manganello
as long as you hit the hard g manganello
or
manganello is if you are going to talk
dirty about me
in italy joe manganiello's butt is the
butts
of butts hashtag butt is that like
the equivalent of the king of beers the
butts of butts
who awakened your bisexuality for me
it was joe manganiello well thank you
for admitting that
publicly my aunt looking at a shirtless
picture of joe manganiello
yeah i'd let him eat crackers in the bed
where are all of these crackers in bed i
don't ever think i've eaten crackers
once in bed was that like an old west
saying like all we had was hard attack
to eat in bed after copulating
i want joe manganiello to rip me in two
then my life will be
fulfilled yep i think that's
slang for something else joe manganiello
as deathstroke is what my bussy deserves
or
[ __ ] actually a good friend of mine
uh actually explained to me what
b-u-s-s-y
means and now i know i'm guessing this
involves cosplay
i'll leave the samurai sword at home i
would happily rip off my arm to have joe
manganello
in my bed but how would you hug me then
apparently joe manganiello is the
creator of death saves
in dnd that fine ass man is also a geek
sophia vergara is living my dream
yes i have a streetwear line called
death saves a geek i guess yeah
you know intellectual i called joe
manganiello
daddy in front of my actual daddy i
think that would be awkward for
everybody involved
don't you think i'm always the [ __ ] for
wawa
and joe manganiello i guess you like
convenience store hot dogs
i mean the fact that i'm in that
category of happiness with convenience
store hot dogs are slushies
like i'll take it joe manganiello is so
[ __ ] fit
i'd lick barbecue sauce off of his
pecs as long as it wasn't like a
super high heat count i would allow that
as you get into the hotter sauces
you start to get some burning on the
skin especially the nipples are very
tender
my husband keeps asking for a threesome
and i'm all like
sure but i didn't know you knew joe
manganiello
i don't think you know my wife sofia
vergara
she's colombian i don't think she's
gonna go for that
joe manganiello is 6'5 with exclamation
points in a question mark i want a
piggyback ride
followed by sexy time is this all
happening in your mind
at some sort of county fair maybe
there's a fantasy about hurting your
ankle
or something and needed to be carried
around i just want to stuff joe
manganiello in my bra
and never let him out that's a big bra i
would even allow you to have a baby
bjorn
just to make it easier i don't care if
joe manganiello has a wife
i want him to pork me well i love the
use of the word
pork i haven't heard that since national
lampoon's vacation
good for you for using the 80s movie
term pork i want joe manganiello to give
me
beard burn on my thighs well
you're catching me at a point with a
goatee we gotta we gotta catch up we're
out of shape for the next roll
i'm not saying that i'd let joe
manganello
raw me into the ground but i am saying
that i'm whole h-o-l-e
okay i mean this is descriptive i think
we have some
some great imaginations rami into the
ground
is going to enter my lexicon i know i'm
going to start using that phrase
a lot more than i currently do those
were pretty
uh pretty funny and imaginative thanks
to everybody who
wrote them i think we have a lot of
young literary talent
is my big takeaway from all of these
thank you buzzfeed
for such a crazy experience and go see
archenemy in theaters and on video on
demand
december 11th thanks everybody
you